things are looking bright for one of
Marvel Comics darkest characters while
critics have user reviews to tear venom
limb from stretchy limb the film going
masses appear to really be growing
attached to the symbiotic superhero
movie and they've unexpectedly sent the
film's audience approval rating soaring
on Rotten Tomatoes by the end of films
opening weekend a Sony Pictures
production was sporting a surprisingly
stellar 89 percent audience approval
score on Rotten Tomatoes a huge
difference compared to its much lower
critical score on the site the audience
rating as a result of more than 16,000
votes seeming to indicate that quite a
few film goers made a point of hitting
at Rotten Tomatoes after seeing the
movie to let their thoughts be known the
apparently positive audience reaction is
obviously a huge turnaround from up
reviewers thoughts men venom slithered
its slimy body onto the silver screen at
the start of October movie critics
weren't exactly loving with a symbiote
and its host had to offer the very first
reports weren't terrible but they seemed
split on how to feel about the not quite
a superhero superhero flick some found
the relationship between Tom Hardy's
Eddie Brock and the alien venom to be a
highlight while others found join the
movies humour whether it was intentional
or not but the inconsistent tone of the
movie along with its failure to follow
through on some of its more interesting
elements were major points of contention
in these first impressions when Sony
Pictures lifted his review embargo the
floodgates opened and critics took their
knives out on venom some argued the
movie was so bad as good while others
contended that the whole thing was just
plain bad
and since it's free optical release
venomous sputtered to a poetry 31%
critical approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes which would seem to mark the
ruben fleischer directed movie as a
certified stinker Richard Roeper with
the Chicago sun-times
slam the movie as a tone-deaf and even
and maddeningly dumb clunker that never
settles on an identity another critic
venomously described the production as a
chaotic and focused assembly edit of a
movie that appears to have had all the
vitality and humanity parasitically
sucked out of it yikes
though critics and general audiences
don't always come to the same conclusion
regarding the quality of a film venom
appears to be a particularly unique case
as there's a significant difference
between the way professional reviewers
and the casual moviegoers are reacting
to the movie if you go by the numbers
from the high audience score to the
record-setting opening weekend it seems
like audiences are straight up loving
this movie venom is hardly the first
movie that critics and audiences have
clashed over like this in 2017 only 40
percent of professional reviewers gave
the Justice League movie a positive
rating while 74 percent of the audience
voters claimed to have enjoyed it a
similar sequence of events played out in
2016 with Suicide Squad the critical
score for a super villain team-up flick
came in at 28% but once audiences saw
for themselves
60% of Rotten Tomatoes voters gave it a
positive rating other critics wrong or a
some audiences just that easy to please
it's hard to say for certain perhaps the
most infamous reads an example of
critics and fans fiercely disagreeing
about the movie's merits came in
December 2017 with star wars the last
Jedi but in that instance the situation
was flipped with 91% of reviewers loving
right - director Rian Johnson's entry in
the franchise fans of the series however
seemed to largely revolt against the
sentiment with only 45% of users saying
they enjoyed it so it just goes to show
this is a phenomenon that goes both ways
Venom's opening weekend brought in over
205 million dollars worldwide
coupled with the sky-high audience score
the people in charge at Sony will likely
be encouraged to press on with plans to
turn venom into the start of a
full-fledged cinematic universe using
the movie as a springboard to launch
other stories from Sony's spider focus
table of Marvel characters with this
kind of reception we're almost
definitely getting a venom 2
hopefully one that can thread the needle
a little better and serve up something
critics and audiences both love
[Music]